suck it up corey bush defends hiring
private security guards while demanding
america defund
police this is brilliant she said i'm
going to make sure that i have security
because
i know i man i could just emphasize all
the eyes
and i have to have too much work to do
there are too many people that need help
right now for me
to allow that wow that is someone who
should just not be given any more power
in any other context for the rest of
their life
like they have already fallen into the
perfect totalitarian mindset i'm more
important than the average person so a
different set of rules should apply to
me
check it out in her one sentence she
says i'm going to make sure that i
have security because i know i had a
tamson
my life and i have too much too much
work to do there are too many people
that need help right now for me to a
seven in one sentence wow
incredible that is really wow yeah
and i'm someone who says i a lot as well
but i'm impressed you the tim cast irl
it's in my name
yeah that's right yeah yeah she says so
if i end up spending 200 000
if i spend 10 more dollars on it you
know what i get to be here to do the
work she had so suck it up
defunding the police has to happen we
need to defund the police and put that
money into social safety nets okay to be
fair said we in that sentence well she
said we
so that means she's a woman of the
people i'm convinced
this is i mean it's the perfect example
of moral licensing right
can can anybody question the squad on
their stance on guns
i think that's a really important thing
because the left like like real leftists
they like
they like guns yes yeah yeah and so
their support base are progressives
what will the progressives think like
where are they at on this one i don't
think anyone's ever like okay is your
cortez how do you feel about guns
well here's the thing i mean gun control
is a losing issue for the left so i
wouldn't be surprised if a lot of their
base is very much in favor of guns and
would be against the gun restrictions
that
the more moderate democrats tend to push
for i think it's establishment democrats
that are anti-gun
exactly leftists are pro-gun like uh i
think a good portion of like union
democrat
democrat like working guys yeah if they
still exist yeah probably there are some
no i know some yeah
and the days of uh ballistic fabrication
have evolved i mean you can
you can 3d print weaponry now that
couldn't didn't exist 20 years ago that
the whole idea of legislating illegality
to something that people can do in their
house
is insane i don't know i mean like you
can make meth in your house i mean i
guess
i
physically but not legally yeah yeah no
that's that's my point i mean but then
the drug war has been a failure but like
clearly we can legislate things you can
make in your house but i agree it makes
it a lot more difficult and it's going
to be a massive uphill battle
for the people who want to regulate guns
not only because
as you said you can make these things in
your house and the technology is
improving but because the vast majority
of the public isn't on board with that
agenda do you ever hear about that guy
who made a radio radiation death ray in
his garage
and he like irradiated his whole
neighborhood and so the government found
out because they were getting this crazy
like really intense reading
and he had taken a bunch of common like
radioactive materials because they exist
all over the place
and he like made a big cluster of it and
then he put it in like
i i could be i could be getting the
story wrong so someone factored me
because i just read it on the internet
somewhere
but he created like a lead casing with a
hole and then he put
all of this radio radioactive material
in it and it focused the radiation out
of it
and so apparently they came and like
shut him down he got offered a job then
kept doing illegal stuff with radiation
it was like covered in lesions so they
like oh my goodness
kicked him out of whatever they were
doing i was just thinking just real
quick i bring that up because
of what you your point was like that
self like home fabrication of things it
literally happens
but the the reason i brought up 2a in
the first place in the context of the
squad is
corey bush says defund the police all
right
and many of the leftists have said try
to abolish the police now here's the
problem i have with their view on this
is that
they want private security for
themselves yes they don't want you to
have guns
and they want to take away your police
that is anarcho tyranny to the most
extreme degree
my position is abolish the police and
give everyone guns by mandate
i was just thinking like if you if you
establish a global second amendment
um like how often do civilians from one
country ever get
charged with attacking another country
it's like in the last
400 years there was that guy in san
francisco who shot that woman so like
but i mean like military like military
escapades in the last 400 years i can't
really pick
like a citizen attack on another country
it's always the government
so if these citizens were armed we would
probably see a lot less war
you know here's arming the citizens
doesn't necessarily mean you get rid of
the military in that country right you'd
still have a military but you'd also
have an armed citizenry on both sides
so oh and i get what you're saying yeah
you know my my view of it is
like uh so i've i've been saying abolish
the police just because i see
i see what's going on with you know the
metro police in dc and the capitol
police
what happened with that guy in his own
home getting arrested what happened in
seattle with the cops
actually defending antifa and i'm like
dude call their bluff call them out say
just okay
people should have a right to defend
themselves and if you know if cops
aren't gonna
are gonna do it right but my view is uh
give everybody guns
right second amendment do you have right
to keep their arms okay then if we're
gonna have universal health care we're
gonna have
universal guns as well but i'll put it
really really simply
i don't see people in their cars just
like randomly like
crashing into houses and like hit
slamming the gas and slamming in the old
ladies or anything like
how is it that people have access to
this very powerful machine
that can just hit somebody and they
don't they don't
i i kind of think people don't want to
kill other people for the most part
yeah i mean look there are a lot of
traffic fatalities and you also have a
lot of accidental gun deaths but
generally speaking people aren't going
out and killing each other
now before 2020 violent crime was on a
downward trend so we could say something
like that and have data to back us up
more strongly but unfortunately because
of the summer of rage as they call it
crime rights have more or less spiked
again and we'll see how long they stay
up for whether they decline
i'm sure they will but who knows maybe
things actually just get worse
and we can't make the case that people
will be peaceful with their guns but
they'll still need them to protect them
so
this is my position on on cops right now
i mean you look at what happens with
with uh chauvin he gets arrested in
charge that that kim woman that kim
potter and she gets arrested and charged
and i'm like if if everything is going
to be beholden to the far left the last
thing we need is a police force to
enforce the whims of the far left sorry
so you know when cory bush comes out
she's like we're going to defund the
police i'm like better do it now before
they take more control in government and
then start using the cops against
regular working-class people
i don't know um we got to clarify like
what does that mean defund yeah please
because i know when vash was on the show
a couple nights ago he
immediately thought the anarcho a
version of it which is completely
removed the funding
so so abolish basically he also said it
hadn't happened
and i was like there was a report last
year was like 265 departments
had like their budget slashed by
substantial numbers i think new york
slashed a billion right
billion so that's that's a defunding not
an abolishment i mean look i believe law
and order is very
important on the one hand on the other
hand i think there maybe is something to
allowing these left-wing cities to
engage in some self-sabotage and see how
that goes for them and maybe that
corrects some of the bad thinking
ultimately i would leave it up more to
local
uh governments and regions to determine
what their police force should look like
and you know what i'll clarify this too
i didn't say about abolish the sheriffs
or you know or troopers i'm talking
about these big cities where things are
like run by democrats and then the
democrats complain about their own
mistakes
i'm like okay i don't live there you
know when you have a baby or a child
that's like don't touch the hot stove
kid and then the kid's like uh
and wants to do it and you're like what
are you gonna do eventually you got to
let him
live his life if he touches the stove he
burns his finger and he realizes
i shouldn't do that again you can't
spend your whole life keeping the kid
out of the kitchen
so in a way maybe we should let these
cities rip their police departments
apart
i i think if that's what they want if
that's who they vote for
then either here's the way i see it
right like i mentioned first and
foremost i look at what happened when
there was like a bunch of right-wing
dudes in portland or whatever and the
cops started beating them up
yeah then there that then you've got
obviously the the the capital police
crying and saying trump's racist and all
that stuff
and then you see the guy in milwaukee
who gets arrested for after people were
at his house threatening his own house
yes
now that that you know right right on
the surface it's like okay there's
clearly an issue there but the other
there's another two issues that i think
are important if the democrats come out
and say they want to abolish or defund
their police i'm like first of all i
don't live there
and i'm more libertarian so i say well
then they can run their community as
they see fit within reason
maybe they're right maybe they're right
huh
it'll be a utopia with no police highly
doubt it well hey
and maybe they're wrong and then maybe
regular people in these cities will be
like wow we shouldn't vote for those
people i think a lot of those people
will leave though to be honest
it's already happening a lot of people
are leaving the cities the property
values are decreasing i mean chicago has
been shrinking that's my point of
reference
everyone's crossing the border over to
indiana because they want to live
somewhere that's sensibly run and they
want to vote for
policies which are not sensible so they
can destroy the the way they did the
place they just came from well to be
honest there's a lot of places in
indiana that have already been destroyed
now
that's fair that's very fair yeah yeah
you go over to gary and it's like yeah
yeah yeah for those that aren't familiar
gary is like the armpit of america
gary i think gary illinois
gary indiana and englewood and chicago
like go back and forth for murder
capital oh wow so there's no really
gary's like heavily industrialized isn't
it it's like the industrial zone of your
apocalyptic brotherhood it was yeah it
was a long time ago and they had a steel
industry and then
i left before the 80s last time i went
to gary it was crazy
because you'd go to like a a block like
a residential block
and every fourth house was a house and
in between it was just
abandoned falling apart chaos and it was
really weird to see like a regular house
sitting right there like a car and then
like everything destroyed next to it
you walk down the street and there's a
school windows blown out
the whole the craziest thing man the
school there's like records of the
the children who went there in the 60s
just everywhere you could walk up pick
up someone's file
find their name wow build things like
that all over the place actually so what
happened was the police went in and just
started breaking windows and destroying
houses and it was all because it was
hunting people down
that's right right the police were
responsible and and
then they defunded the police and now
gary doesn't have many police and it's
going great
interesting phenomena in the united
states all these like ghost town type
these rubber boom like
it's very interesting i was born in
akron in ohio and there's a rubber boom
city after goodyear was formed there in
the 50s and 40s and then uh
when the rubber boom stopped it became a
ghost town but not like gary
gary had akron didn't have chicago right
next door so gary's like the beat up
aftermath of a ghost town yeah
i find it fascinating there's all these
different cities there's another report
that found
democrats in all of these cities that
had defunded police were hiring massive
private security
oh interesting this is what it was like
when i was growing up in chicago i
remember my dad used to say that
these these politicians in chicago would
always vote for more gun restrictions
and then have private security guards
with guns exactly they
can have guns yes i can have a gun to
protect myself i'll have a private
security force to protect my family
put those stupid peasants out there let
them have five round magazines
yep if they can have a gun at all yeah
what does she think
corey bush think is the point what does
she want to do
defund the police what does she mean
like get like social workers to go
on calls of domestic abuse and yes she
said social
what did she say social safety nets does
she understand that like
domestic abuse is some of the most
dangerous situations a human can
can walk into two enraged people in the
middle of a fight
well i don't know about to enrage people
often you get you'll get like a dude
abusing a woman it is true that women
abuse men as well but it's
disproportionately
men abusing women right and that's why
i'm like ladies
you need to have proper training and
firearms man
dude i heard this i used to live next
door to this couple and i could hear
them through the walls and and
they were they would fight a lot and one
night i heard the guy come home
and then i heard the girl like me
and the guy was like meh and she was
like and the guy was like
and she she enraged the guy and then the
guy started
beating her and i called the cops but
like she and she instigated it
it was crazy how domestic abuse is like
this six
can can be a six cycle that both people
become like used to
well look you i can call you a bunch of
dirty names that doesn't mean you should
take
no he was in the wrong i called the cops
on him right tracking
and you're right you're right police
show up to that and that's some of the
most dangerous stuff they could
encounter
here's a guy who's attacking somebody
you don't know what's going on and
sometimes the guy's innocent even
there's like a lot of these stories are
kind of scary too i think it's
disproportionate but there are stories
where it's like the woman calls the cops
and the guy and i didn't do anything and
the cops come and arrest the guy
it's tough job man i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna there's no two words about it and
what do you do
do we just say like both the men and
women should be armed and then when the
fight breaks out they shoot each other
obviously not that's why when i talk
about the police
i think the police are important i think
they do a hard job i think they do
a a mostly good job and i think it's
it's it's
uh a fairly thankless in a lot of ways
because people don't like getting
tickets
they don't like getting tickets they
don't they don't like being told no
and then they get pulled over and
they're like you singled me out and
they're all angry and it's like well you
know man don't
you know speed or whatever the issue
right now is just it's it's way too hot
politically
and the cultural institutions being
controlled by leftist ideologues i'm
like i'll tell you what's going to
happen man
because we've already seen it and i've
already said it 50 million times
they're gonna you know they're gonna
show up to your house or take away your
guns they're gonna serve you a red flag
warrant
they're gonna arrest you for defending
yourself and they're gonna let the
extremists smash up windows and do
whatever they want
so i'm like i like sheriffs tend to do a
good job there's some bad stories about
sheriffs but
if these big cities don't want their
cops i'm going to advocate for that
my feeling is it's going to be either
socialized police like what we kind of
have now
federalized police or private police
that it will be one of those three
if not a mixture of all three which we
kind of have now so i'm afraid that if
we
defund police socialized police that
we're gonna have an influx of either
federal or private
yep and that's that's terrifying i'd
rather have local
yes well that's what aoc said when asked
like what what would you be looking for
and she said we wanted to be more like
the suburbs
well that's a good point let's bring it
back to the days officer friendly right
what does she mean by that
i guess she's saying that like in the
suburbs the cop will pull you over and
be like how's it going there ian
good day you are speeding again and then
you're going to be like i'm sorry
officer smith back well you slow down
there
son then he and then he leaves and he's
like my dad was a fireman they knew my
dad did you know your crosslands kid
white proof get out of here white
privilege here's a warning one time i
got a warning yeah
that was was fireman privilege fireman
city worker privilege
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you